Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, hat die Bundesregierung eigentlich Easter Eggs?
So wie die rumeiern schon.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 457 vom 8.
April 2023 und heute mal live.
Früh am Morgen, wie immer, in Hamburg auf dem Easter Egg 20, dazu gleich noch mehr.
Und wir sagen Hallo, vielen Dank fürs Wasser, Hallo, herzlich willkommen,
alle die hier gekommen seid. Hallo, es gibt nur ein Wasser.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt teilen.
Okay, gut. Wir müssen uns das jetzt verdienen. Ich hab jetzt aufgebaut,
deswegen krieg ich eine Flasche Wasser und dann je nach Performance sehen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Also wenn wir so weitermachen, kriegen wir hier nur noch Zielwasser.
Genau, wir stoßen jetzt gleich mal erstmal an, weil wir sind durstig,
auf 20 mal, vorsichtig in der Formulierung, 20 mal Issaac. Immerhin.
Wer kommt zu mir?
Ja. Achtung, drei, zwei, eins.
Und dieser Easter Egg ist, glaub ich, auch der am häufigsten geplante Easter Egg, ne?
Nicht ganz 20 Mal.
Ich unterhielt mich hier gerade mit Ron, vielen sicherlich auch bekannt aus
den Security Nightmares.
Und der sagte, sag mal wie oft war das denn jetzt eigentlich hier schon auf Kampnagel?
Und dann sagte ich, kein einziges Mal. Er so, echt nicht? Ich seh,
das wurde nur viermal angekündigt.
2020, ich weiß nicht.
Viermal?
Drei Mal. 2021, 2022.
Das ist glaube ich dreimal ausgefallen.
Drei Mal ausgefallen. 20, 21, 22, 23.
Achso, ja.
Wäre für mich viermal angekündigt.
Viermal angekündigt, dreimal ausgefallen.
Viermal geplant, einmal durchgeführt.
Ja, das ist ein gut geplantes Event.
Hoffen wir.
Genau, und da sind wir jetzt hier auf der Bühne in K2. K steht für Kampnagel,
das ist nämlich das Venue, wie man so schön sagt.
Der Ort, wo wir uns hier zusammen finden und ich bin glaube ich das erste Mal
hier auf einer Veranstaltung, wenn ich mich so richtig erinnere.
Ihr schon mal hier irgendwie?
Öfter, ja.
Geraved, ja. Aber du bist ja von hier, ne?
Ich bin von hier, ja.
Du bist von hier, ne?
Es ist nett, dass ihr mal hergekommen seid.
Ja, so sind wir. Stimmt aber nicht, ich bin neulich schon mal vorbeigekommen.
Ja das stimmt, das wollte ich jetzt nicht lügen.
Ja, okay, na gut, macht ja nix. Macht ja nix. Ja, hallo Khaleesi.
Hallo. Euch Hörerinnen und Hörern sicherlich schon bekannt, weil du warst ja
jetzt schon ein paar Mal dabei.
Und da das jetzt dein Home-Turf ist, dachten wir uns, erzählst du uns mal hier
was von deiner Hood und wie das so läuft hier.
Dodger bitte auf Bühne, ich weiß nicht wie die Bühne heißt, in K2 bitte.
Ich muss ehrlich zugeben, ich war mit EU Politik beschäftigt und weniger mit
Easter Egg Planung zu meiner Schande. Ich hab den ersten angefangen mit zu planen,
also in 2019, für 2020 und dann nicht mehr. Dann kam ja schon fast die Chatkontrolle.
Verstehe. Politische Verstrickung kam dazwischen.
So, was haben wir denn noch anzukündigen, bevor wir hier in Medias Res gehen?
Ich glaube schon alles interessante passiert. Systemabsturzkonzert war schon,
Schunkelmusik DJ-Set war schon, Khaleesi's Vortrag war schon,
Kreuzigung war auch schon, war gestern Freitag.
Wer ist gekreuzigt worden diesmal? Weiß ich nicht, aber...
Kreuzigung, es war doch Karfreitag oder? Die Kreuzigung?
Deswegen darf man da nicht tanzen, deswegen musste auch gestern spezifisch das
Konzert sein und das DJ Set.
Wieso hat da jetzt keiner getanzt? Nein, deswegen hat man euch als DJ Set eingeladen.
Ja, danke.
Wie gesagt, es hängt am Ende immer alles von der professionellen Planung ab.
Das sind so diese Aspekte, die kommen. Für die Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, was ein Easterhack ist.
Ein Easterhack ist so eine Art Zwischenkongressveranstaltung,
wie sie sich ja so einige in den letzten Jahrzehnten, muss man ja mittlerweile
sagen, herausgebildet haben im CCC-Umfeld.
Einfach weil das Missverhältnis zwischen Kongress und der...
Und ja.
Und dazwischen und ja, genau. So ein bisschen,
ja, das lief alles so ein bisschen auseinander und die Größe der Veranstaltung,
also das Wachstum des Kongresses schuf Bedürfnisse, kleinere Veranstaltungen
zu haben, überschaubare, regionalere Veranstaltungen.
Und da ist ja so einiges entstanden.
MRM-CD, die GPN, oh Gott, jetzt habe ich angefangen die aufzuzählen,
da vergesse ich natürlich wie viel ich hätte.
Ich habe gerade gedacht, nein. Ja, ja, Entschuldigung, es tut mir leid.
Aber ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Und der Isar-Heck war dann im Prinzip so
eine Art Homecoming für Hamburg, weil ja dann der Kongress zu dem Zeitpunkt
nach Berlin abgewandert war.
Und da konnte man halt auch wieder in das gute alte kleine muffige Eidelstädter
Bürgerhaus, wie damals.
Ja, die alten Säcke unter euch erinnern sich vielleicht noch.
Aber auch das ist jetzt mittlerweile wieder zu klein geworden und deswegen jetzt
hier mit tausend Leuten. Und hat es euch soweit gepasst?
Jetzt Reaktionen des Publikums einspielen.
Okay? Sehr.
Naja, also danke an die Organ, alle die hier mitgeholfen haben.
Tolle Veranstaltung und wir fühlen uns wohl. Ja. Kommen wir zum Thema.
Wir fangen mit Feedback an.
Okay, ich seh schon, dass der Sekt, den Elmar Iaci uns hier hingestellt hat, wirkt. Wirkt.
Das ist nicht der Sekt, das ist die Eiswürfel.
Ihr habt noch mit der Werbung, die Werbung habt ihr vergessen.
Achso, ja stimmt ja.
Also, Werbung.
Es gibt Aufkleber, ja.
Genau, wir haben Aufkleber mitgebracht, die gibt es dann da hinten in der Kiste
bzw. auf dem Tisch, da könnt ihr euch dann ordentlich mit eindecken. Denn all für Euch.
Natürlich nicht für euch, sondern für entsprechende werbende Flächen.
Stohrtüren.
Genau, da muss das dann drauf.
Laternenpfähle.
Du bist ja bescheid.
Hinten an Autos dran.
Genau, oder auf Nazi-Aufkleber auch.
Über Nazi-Aufkleber auch drüber.
Dafür sind die eigentlich auch gemacht.
Ja.
Genau.
Okay, aber jetzt, genau, die gibt's da hinten und Shirts gibt's nicht.
Hast du nicht geschafft.
Ne, ja, nein.
Tim hat versucht die Shirts hier von den Engeln vorne verkaufen zu lassen.
Was?
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das ist aber mit dem Volk gescheitert.
Das ist nicht wahr.
Einer mit dem Versuch gescheitert.
Nein, das ist nicht wahr. Nein, nein, das lag einfach an meinen Hobbys. Okay. Ja, genau.
Nicht so viel programmieren, mehr Shirts drucken, Tim.
Programmieren ist gut für die Gesundheit, das kann ich dir sagen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Doch, für die Mentale. Es kommt immer drauf an. Es kommt drauf an,
was man programmiert, wie man programmiert. Darauf kommt es natürlich an,
aber wenn man das richtig macht, ist es auch wie mit Sport. Sport kann auch Mord sein.
Würde ich jetzt so nicht unterschreiben, aber das ist eine Diskussion für einen Muskelkater.
Es gibt Leute, die sich dabei verletzen.
Ja, du zum Beispiel?
Ich verletze mich dann beim Programmieren.
Hahaha. Genau, ich hab so eine Mentalbeule.
Ja, nee, das macht auf jeden Fall Spaß. Kommen wir zum Feedback.
Wir haben über einiges gesprochen, aber ich dachte mir, jetzt nehmen wir nur
das unterhaltsame Feedback.
Das stimmt natürlich nicht, weil jegliches Feedback ist in irgendeiner Form
unterhaltsam. Euer Feedback ist besonders unterhaltsam.
Aber wo ja richtig alle aus den Sitzen gesprungen sind, das war natürlich unsere
Einlassung zum Gesundheitssystem und den Ärzten und der Digitalisierung, Dauerbrenner.
Habe es hier auch noch mal einen Talk dazu. Diesmal haben sich vor allem die
Ärztinnen und Ärzte zu Wort gemeldet und haben so ein bisschen aus ihrem Nähkästchen geplaudert.
Los ging's mit...
Leute denkt euch mal einfachere, das ist mit diesen Nicknames so eine Sache,
vor 20 Jahren da konnte man sich noch Nücks nennen und irgendwie drei Buchstaben,
vier Buchstaben, hat alles gepasst, gab's alles, Twitter war frei, pipapo.
Wenn du heute irgendwie als Jungnerd auf die Landschaft triffst,
dann musst du dir schon Generatoren einführen.
Die Nick-Beratung machen. Also wir haben uns schon überlegt,
man sollte einen Nick-Beratungs-Workshop machen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall dringend gebraucht.
Ja und was sind so die Kriterien für einen guten Nickname?
Ob man den fühlt, würden wir jungen Menschen sagen.
So wie Khaleesi.
Den habe ich ja bekommen.
Achso, den habe ich mir nicht ausgesucht. Bei mir hat ja ein Nickname nie verfangen.
Nee, aber wir können dich auch gerne TomTom nennen.
Nee, er wollte aber Theodor Prinz genannt werden.
Nein, Theodor Prinz heiße ich.
Achso, ja.
Das ist was ganz anderes. Nee, aber so ein Nickname, irgendwie hat es nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, heutzutage, keine Ahnung, seit wieviel Jahren Tim irgendwie in der
Geburtsnamen-Statistik in den Top Ten steht, schon eine Weile.
Aber als ich so in die Welt geworfen wurde, hieß ja kein Mensch Tim,
also nicht in Deutschland zumindest.
Und dann war das so die Zeit der Arcade-Automaten, wo halt nur drei Buchstaben
in die Highscore-Liste gingen.
Da will man sich doch keinen nicknennen, wenn man Tim heißt, verstehst du?
Ja, T1M hättest du noch machen können, um so ein bisschen...
Ich war auch solid genug. Ja. Also, Meninguenzep schreibt, ist das vielleicht
irgendwie rückwärts? Pitzen? Ne.
Also das ist das Problem mit diesen Nicknames heutzutage.
Ich bin Arzt im Krankenhaus und ich hoffe in der Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens
auf nichts mehr. Es gibt zwei Szenarien.
Erstens, wir bleiben für immer in der aktuellen Papierhülle,
wo ich 30 Minuten damit verbringe, Vorbefunde von einer verpixelten Kopie abzutippen,
mit Patienten auszudiskutieren, welcher der fünf Medikamentenpläne,
die sie gerade in ihrer Hosentasche gefunden haben, der aktuellste ist.
Ich dann eine Untersuchungsanforderung an eine Faxnummer schicke,
wo jemand meine Handschrift entziffern und doch in einen Computer eingeben muss
Und ich dann Untersuchungsbefunde nur per Screenshot in den Arztbrief einfügen
kann, weil selbst innerhalb des Hauses die Systeme keine strukturierten Daten,
sondern teilweise nur PDFs austauschen.
Dafür sind die Daten sehr sicher, wir kommen ja selbst nicht mal richtig dran.
Es war nicht alles schlecht, es war nicht alles schlecht.
Szenario 2, könnte mal aufhören mich hier während der Veranstaltung anzurufen, verdammte Axt.
War dein Arztbrief der angerufen hat.
Szenario 2, wir kommen in die dystopische Zukunft, wo alle Patienten einen riesigen
Dump an Daten mit sich herum tragen, den niemand kuratiert oder aktuell hält,
Denn das System, um die Daten zu bearbeiten, ist furchtbar zu benutzen.
Braucht zwei Minuten, um zu laden und man bekommt nur 1,67 Euro im Quartal dafür.
Ich kann eine Untersuchung jetzt in einem SAP-Formular statt auf Papier anmelden.
Dafür darf ich das Formular jetzt nicht abschicken, bis ich nicht noch fünf
weitere völlig irrelevante Informationen ausgefüllt habe, weil irgendjemand
bei der Einrichtung die Felder auf verpflichtend gestellt hat.
Meine 75-jährigen Patienten unterschreiben bei 17 Seiten Informed-Consent,
dass alle ihre Daten jetzt der Allgemeinheit nützen sollen.
Dafür stehen mir jetzt alle Daten des Patienten zur Verfügung.
Ich muss den nur in einem Heuhaufen zwischen PDF-Scans und Stuhlgangsbeschreibung von 2009 rausfischen.
Also, anders gesagt, European Health Data Space.
Das Thema ist abschließend erörtert, würde ich sagen.
Das denkst du. Denn dazu kommentiert Lipfi, Lipfi hatte noch Glück irgendwie, fünf Buchstaben.
Haha, ich arbeite in einem MVZ-Labor mit relativ guten Probenaufkommen dank
umliegende Hausarzt- und Klinikeinsendungen Ich kann da so gut mitführen,
was für ein Abfuck die Bürokratie sein kann, obgleich man gleichzeitig eigentlich
nur zügig den Kollegen Befunde zukommen lassen möchte.
Aber selbst wenn das alles klappt mit der Digitalisierung, heißt das ja nicht
automatisch, dass es alles besser wird.
Dann haben wir halt trotzdem zehn Anforderungsarten von 10a, kleiner Igel und Co.
digitalisiert. Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll, kleiner Igel und Co.
Und automatisiert. Meiner Meinung nach ist dieses private und gesetzliche Kassenwirrwarr
eine Sache, die man im Zuge der Digitalisierung erst einstampfen sollte.
Ein Pott, alle Zahlen rein, alles wird daraus bezahlt, fertig.
Das bei bestimmten Parametern, die privaten Proben zweimal gefahren werden,
aber bei Blutgruppenausweisen für, das ist ein bisschen kaputt geschrieben,
Schwangere oder so, zwar automatisch mitgemessen, dann der Wert aber storniert wird,
weil die Kassen ihn nicht automatisch bezahlen. Setzt dem Ganzen noch ein Krönchen auf.
Und Blutkonserven bestellen wir beim BSD, teilweise immer noch mit Fax.
Wie Linus mal sinngemäß zum Thema D-Mail kommentierte, wenn du Scheiße digitalisierst,
hast du halt digitale Scheiße. Ich finde man sollte dieses Gesamtkonzept Gesundheitswesen hinterfragen.
Also es ist schon erkennbar, dass das eine Branche mit Leidensdruck zu sein scheint.
Kann man wohl sagen. Also in den Kommentaren, es ging, also das nahm gar kein
Ende. Eins hab ich noch. Götz. Ich bin Kinder- und Jugendarzt.
Jeden Tag kommen und gehen 100 bis 150 Kinder mit Eltern rein und raus.
Da summiert sich selbst 30 Sekunden pro Eintrag in eine EPA zu größer eine Stunde Arbeit.
Arbeit haben wir schon genug. Jede Woche an die 60 Stunden. Das meiste macht
Spaß. Aber jetzt noch die EPA.
Die nützt weder Patient noch sonst wem. Wenn die Digitalisierung außer der IT-Industrie,
ein Klammern, Konnektoren-Tausch sinnvoll wäre, dann setzte sie sich ganz allein durch.
Wie das Telefon, das Tablet, der Computer, das WC. Alles sinnvoll und hat sich durchgesetzt.
Beispiel TI. Tausende für Anschaffung und Betrieb eines Connectors.
Einziger Zweck, Abgleich, ob der Patient tatsächlich noch bei der Kasse versichert
ist, deren Karte er vorlegt. E-Arbeitsfähigkeitsbescheinigung.
Früher drei Ausdrucke, drei Unterschriften.
Gut. Jetzt einmal elektronisch signiert an der Kasse, einmal für Patient ausdrucken.
Dann zur Sicherheit den Ausdruck für den Arbeitgeber, denn der ist nicht angeschlossen.
Wenn ein Abend signiert wird nach Feierabend, dann sehe ich die Rückmeldung,
dass die EAU der Kasse nicht übermittelt werden konnte.
Ausdrucken, Briefumschlag, Porto. Oder die Meldung ist nicht bei der Kasse versichert.
Liegt ein Sinn darin? Ich werde es nie verstehen. Doch das Leben wird immer weitergehen.
Meine Güte.
Applaus Ich, also, weißt du, was soll ich noch sagen?
Letzter Kommentar noch von Matthias Pansenböck. Bezüglich Arztpraxen-Software,
ich weiß von einem Arzt hier in Österreich, der noch DOS verwendet.
Mit Disketten und so. Und während der Behandlung erzählte der lauter Verschwörungstheorien.
Ich hab da den Arzt gewechselt.
Oh mein, ja, das ist alles ganz schlimm und furchtbar.
Aber dieser Leidensdruck, der, ich dachte das wäre nur in meiner Branche so.
Das beruhigt mich gewissermaßen.
Das einzige Paradies ist Podcasting.
Also dann schon lieber Patient.
Da höre ich auch immer wieder schlimme Sachen.
Kommen wir jetzt zum weiteren Feedback. Wie sollte es auch anders sein?
Noch ein Nachtrag zu Sack und Beutel.
Packstut, der uns schon mal mit einem schönen Kommentar gesegnet hat,
schreibt, moin ich noch mal. Da habe ich im letzten Kommentar auch glatt vergessen,
euch die korrekte Definition für euer raumbildendes Packmittel mitzuteilen.
Aufgrund der am Beutel angebrachten Tragegriffe handelt es sich nach DIN 55405
selbstverständlich um einen Tada-Tragebeutel.
Wir sind hier immer noch in Deutschland. Selbstverständlich gibt es für die
Terminologie eine eigene Norm. Ich finde die aktuelle Bezeichnung im Shop aber
schon ziemlich gelungen.
Es gibt eine DIN-Norm. Ich möchte nicht, dass wir Tragebeutel verkaufen, die DIN-normiert sind.
Sondern welche? Welche Normierung hälst du gerne?
Ich möchte, dass sie gegen die Norm verstoßen. Die sind nicht normengerecht.
Wir machen einen Henkel ab oder... Okay.
Aber dann müsst ihr auch ein Disclaimer reinmachen, ne?
Klar, natürlich.
Das wird bestimmt der totale Verkaufsschlag.
Nicht normengerechter Tragebäutel. Dieser Tragebäutel...
Nicht normengerechtes raumbildendes Packmittel.
Das wir nicht als Tragebäutel bezeichnen dürfen, weil es nicht normengerecht ist.
Und wenn du dann trotzdem Sachen damit trägst, bist du revolutionär eigentlich.
So viel zum Feedback.
Ich war bei einer Ausstellungseröffnung.
Das heißt Vernissage.
Ne, so heißt das nur bei Kunst.
Achso und was für eine Ausstellung wurde da eröffnet?
Die Ausstellung hieß Deutschland Digital.
Also das ist ja auch irgendwie Kunst. Ist das Kunst oder kann das weg? Wäre da die Frage?
Es war, also tatsächlich ist das vom Haus der Geschichte, in Bonn war das.
Die haben eine ganze Reihe an Ausstellungsstücken vom CCC.
Und zwar beispielsweise ein Pferd,
das gebaut wurde zum Protest gegen, bei der Staatstrojaner-Gesetzgebung,
Ich glaube das wurde dann in Karlsruhe bei dem Verfassungsgericht,
das verhandelt wurde, dort mit aufgefahren.
Das ist Teil dieser Ausstellung.
Dann eine Reihe von unseren Bundestagsauskünften, deren so ausgedruckt und gebunden da liegen.
Dann gab's noch irgendwie so eine Reihe an Interviews, wo eine der Personen
auch ich war und noch was?
Wo war diese Ausstellung?
Bonn, Haus der Geschichte. Und die war aber vorher auch schon mal in Leipzig
und jetzt hatten die den Fehler gemacht, mich zu der Eröffnung einzuladen als Festredner.
Also du bist auch gar nicht normgerecht.
Ich war nicht noch, nein, ich hab vor allem dann gesagt, also Deutschland Digital,
das ist erstens, die Ausstellung muss sehr kurz sein und sehr traurig.
Und es ist auch tatsächlich so.
Ne, aber da waren tatsächlich einige sehr interessante Exponate mit dabei.
Beispielsweise jemand, der zu DDR-Zeiten in der DDR seinen eigenen Computer
gebaut hat und irgendwie,
also wirklich die skurrilsten Objekte irgendwie gesourcet hat,
um dann einen Computer da selber zu bauen und wunderschöne Exponate,
aber natürlich auch ein Roboter oder so, der dann da rumfährt und so.
Kann man schon machen. Und die konzentriert sich auf drei Bereiche,
Arbeit und Wirtschaft, Politik und Gesellschaft und dann so das Privatleben.
Also die drei Bereiche, die ja so die Digitalisierung beeinflusst hat.
Und kann man auf jeden Fall mal besuchen, wenn man in Bonn ist. Also wenn man da ist.
Ja das war ganz nett und ich konnte mir, ich habe einmal so ein bisschen mir
den Frust von der Seele reden können und ich hätte mir gewünscht,
ich hätte so schöne Kommentare über den Zustand des Gesundheitswesens vorher noch gelesen,
aber ich habe mich auch so ein bisschen darüber beschwert oder sagen wir mal
über den Zustand Deutschlands allgemein ein bisschen beklagen können Und es war ganz nett,
weil der Museumsdirektor, der vor mir sprach, sagte so, allenfalls mäßiges Mittelmaß
wäre also die deutsche Digitalisierung.
Aber da sieht man, es ist halt ein Optimist.
Ich hab, es gibt einen, ich versuche gerade herauszufinden, wie denn dieser,
es gibt so ein Geschichtsmuseum mitten in Berlin, in Mitte, warte mal,
wie heißt denn das nochmal?
Aus der Geschichte.
An der Kulturbrauerei ist das.
Ich denke unter den Linden irgendwie kann das sein?
Futurium?
Nee, auch irgendwas mit ganz Staatstragendes, mit bunt irgendwie,
ich weiß es grad nicht mehr.
Und das Tag?
Ja, vielleicht komm ich noch drauf. Auf jeden Fall so eine Entität,
die sich sozusagen auch bemüht darum, solche Artefakte einzusammeln.
Und von denen habe ich mal eine Mail bekommen nach einem Kongress.
Ich krieg das jetzt richtig zusammen. Nach einem Kongress im BCC oder im Haus
am Kölnischen Park vielleicht sogar. Ich glaub sogar noch im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Ja genau.
Und zwar, was sie archiviert haben, waren die Fotos von den Lost and Found Dingern vom Kongress.
Also Sachen sind liegen geblieben auf dem Kongress. Ich hab die dann fotografiert,
auf die Webseite gestellt.
Und das fanden die so faszinierend, was bei so einer Hacker-Konferenz für so Sachen übrig bleiben.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht mehr genau, es waren nicht nur Klamotten,
es war halt alles mögliche Gerät, was kein Mensch sonst hatte.
Das haben die dann irgendwie reingesetzt. Bundesarchiv? Wie gesagt, ich...
Oder vielleicht...
Meine Erinnerung sagt Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Nein, nein.
Irgendwas mit Geschichte. Ich komm noch drauf. Es ist schon wirklich sehr lange her.
Naja, auf jeden Fall fand ich das interessant und ich fand das ganz interessant,
dass sie das so interessant fanden.
So, Bundestag, du hast es schon erwähnt. Ist ja auch so ein Ort der Sehnsucht, oder?
Ich bin auch schon wieder ganz depressiv, dass ich so lange nicht mehr im Bundestag war.
Wieso, wie lange warst du nicht im Bundestag?
Das ist eine gute Frage, wahrscheinlich nur einen Monat.
Monat? Monat, aha, also bist Stammgast sozusagen, ist deine Stammkneipe.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, wir haben das ja hier auch schon berichtet aus der
Ferne, du hattest ja da einen Starauftritt.
Ja, als Elina Eich steht, war ich im Bundestag.
Und undercover sozusagen.
Die Nicks werden echt immer länger.
Also der Nickberater hat mir gesagt, das ist so alles, was an Buchstaben Salat
geht im Deutschen deswegen die Nachname.
Aber immerhin Alliteration ist ja auch was wert.
Ja.
Darf man nicht so wie CCC.
Hat extra gekostet.
Ja wie war es denn? Wie hast du dich denn gefühlt? Es war ja glaube ich das
erste Mal, dass du im Bundestag warst als Sachverständige, wenn ich Untertitel
im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017.
Das ist richtig, am Anfang bin ich erstmal fast rausgeflogen,
Tabea Rösner eröffnete die Sitzung mit, ich muss mal kurz kontrollieren,
ob Menschen Sticker auf ihren Laptops haben.
Politische Willensbekundung oder weshalb?
Ja und ich hab so einen tollen Sticker, den ich mal von einem Freund aus dem
C4 geschenkt bekommen hab, so politische Aktionen mit Antifa-Flaggen auf meinem
Sticker, Aber irgendwie hat sie es dann elegant ignoriert, ich glaube das war
dann zu heikel mich rauszuschmeißen.
Der Kubicki, dieser Sporttrinker da von der FDP, googelt mal Bilder von Kubicki,
der ist die ganze Zeit nur mit Bierglas und so.
Was hast du da? Sekt.
Der hat doch die Martina Renner mal ermahnt oder irgendwie zurecht gewiesen,
weil sie einen kleinen Antifa-Sticker am Rever hatte.
Aber tatsächlich ist ja politische, also quasi Protest oder sowas ist nicht
gern gesehen im Bundestag, also wenn du da jetzt nicht Mitglied bist.
Und insofern kann ich mir das sogar vorstellen, dass das potenziell problematisch
wäre. Aber sie hat dann also deine verfassungsstützenden Organe,
verfassungsstützenden Organisationen hat sie jetzt nicht bemängelt.
Naja ich hab mich auch so ein bisschen gewundert, ich meine gegen Flipkart kann
ich kaum gegen anstinken, ich weiß gar nicht.
Das ist nicht der Laptop, das hier ist mein Netzpolitik Laptop,
ich hatte einen anderen Laptop mit damals.
Okay.
Das ist nicht dieser hier.
Aber okay, du durftest bleiben?
Ich durfte bleiben, ich war ein bisschen irritiert, das war ein kurzer Schockmoment,
ich so okay, Mist, hab ich mir einmal was nicht handschriftlich aufgeschrieben
und jetzt werde ich aus dem Bundestag geworfen.
Es war sehr nett, vor der Anhörung kam eine Bundestagsabgeordnete auf mich zu
und sagte, schön war es wieder, dich in LNP zu hören, aber dass du Gesellschaftsspiele
nicht magst, das geht gar nicht.
Ich so, okay, das tut mir leid.
Schönen Gruß an die Bundestagsabgeordnete, die uns hört.
Genau, aber die Anhörung war dann würde ich sagen, was wurde getitelt? 9 zu 0.
Eine historische Anhörung und deswegen war das irgendwie besonders cool da dabei zu sein.
Einmal Klassenkeile so mit neun Leuten draufhauen und hier nochmal eine positive Erfahrung.
Definitiv. Also ich durfte zwischen dem Oberstaatsanwalt und dem BMI-Menschen
sitzen, das war ein total toller Sitzplatz. Ich hab leider vergessen ihm zum
Geburtstag zu gratulieren, weil es exakt sein Geburtstag war.
Das hattest du besser gemacht bei der letzten Anhörung.
Ich hab dem Herrn Köhnen gratuliert, natürlich.
Ja, hättest du mir mal Bescheid sagen sollen.
Ich teile meine Ursinn nicht über die Leute. Aber okay, also eine positive Erfahrung.
Wie war das mit dem, du hattest, es gab ja Fragerunde rechts rum, links rum, oder?
Welches Spiel haben Sie gespielt?
Ähm, Nachtalphabet, ja. Aber ich war trotzdem ganz vorne.
Niemand mit A, B oder C da? Oder D?
Nee, ich hab angefangen.
Super.
Ich lebe die Alliteration.
Also, dass du angefangen hast, weiß ich ja. Ich wusste nämlich genau wieso,
weil ich vorher nicht so wirklich hingehört habe.
Also positive Erfahrung war es dann dein das Verfassen der Sachverständigenauskunft?
Ob das eine positive Erfahrung war?
Das Verfassen oder das Abliefern?
Also ich war pünktlich, dafür wurde ich auch dann gleich verurteilt.
Tage vorher fertig?
Nein, ich hab's genau an dem Tag an dem es abgegeben worden ist.
Ja, aber wann war die Anhörung? Die war doch drei Tage später oder vier.
Ja, aber ich wollte halt Urlaub machen zwischen euch.
Tja, Profi halt. Kannste mal sehen.
Wir haben da jahrelang mühselig einen Ruf aufgebaut. Und du kannst jetzt nicht
einfach anfangen pünktlich Dinge abzugeben.
Und in Bluse auf Chaos-Events rumzulaufen. Ich weiß, das ist eine Frechheit.
Lass uns da gar nicht erst mit anfangen.
Also ja, ich sag mal die Stellungnahme hat sich ein bisschen von selbst geschrieben,
dadurch, dass ich seit einem Jahr über nichts anderes reden darf,
außer die Chat-Kontrolle. Und immer wenn ich versuche abzubiegen,
sagt irgendjemand, kannst du nicht lieber über die Chatkontrolle reden?
War das gar nicht so dramatisch, die hat sich relativ leicht geschrieben.
Die Fragen, von denen darf man sich ja nicht irritieren lassen,
die sind teilweise sehr seltsam und können auch so Stellungnahmen zerstören,
wenn man sich an sie hält.
Ja und dann habe ich rechtzeitig die Stellungnahme abgegeben.
Wahnsinn. Wie viele Leute sind denn dann so im Raum? Also wenn man da so ist.
Also das haben wir ja gerade nicht gesagt, das war ja der Digitalausschuss,
das heißt irgendwie alle Abgeordneten, die im Digitalausschuss sind,
die Personen, die angehört werden, gegebenenfalls noch Mitarbeitende und Ulrich
Kelber war noch da und jemand von BSI, ich weiß gerade seinen Namen nicht.
Scharphüser.
Scharphüser, genau. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch eine Gästetribüne oben.
Also so 40, 50 offizieller mal so geschätzt, 30 mehr?
Ich würde eher sagen weniger oder? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ja 30 vielleicht.
Es fühlte sich nicht so viel an, muss ich sagen.
Und Publikum?
Ja, ich habe die Menschen gebeten sich außerhalb meines Sichtfeldes zu setzen, aber...
Ach du bist da reingegangen, ihr setzt euch ja alle mal um, ich will euch nicht sehen oder was?
Wenn du wüsstest, wer sie da besucht hat, dann hättest du das auch gemacht.
Ich sehe davon so ein paar Menschen im Publikum.
Ihr wolltet ja nicht kommen.
Ich konnte ja nicht kommen.
Ja, das nenne ich mal Unterstützung.
Wir haben gemütlich im Podcast gesessen und irgendwie Fahnen geweht und alles.
Gab's denn Szenenapplaus oder so? Nein, darf man nicht.
Darf man nicht. Also mein halbes Kollegium war netterweise da,
den hab ich dann vorher gesagt, dass sie nicht klatschen und jubeln dürfen.
Und die haben sich dann gehalten?
Natürlich.
Und du hast pünktlich abgegeben?
Ich habe pünktlich abgeben und mein Eingangsstatement war eine Minute zu kurz.
Ist das von Vorteil?
Weiß ich nicht, das muss Lino sagen, der ist der Experte. Ich hatte das vorher
zu Hause geübt und das war zwei Minuten länger als die Zeit,
deswegen dachte ich, das ist ja kein Problem.
Aber wenn du ein Schnellling gekriegt hast? Schade um die extra Minute.
Die eigentliche Frage ist ja, bewirkt es irgendwas?
Das wollte ich nämlich sagen, die richtige Antwort wäre gewesen,
war nett, aber der schale Beigeschmack, dass nichts von dem was du da sagst,
irgendwo in Betracht gezogen wird, der kommt dann immer erst sehr viel später.
Naja das war mir glaube ich von vornherein klar, also es war so ein bisschen
Chatkontrolle Theater und alle haben nochmal ihr politisches Statement gemacht.
Und so wirklich ins Gewicht fallen tut das jetzt nicht.
Da muss man leider die Menschen enttäuschen, die gedacht haben,
boah, geil, richtig gute Anhörung im Digitalausschuss, jetzt ist das mit der
Chatkontrolle gegessen.
Dem ist halt leider nicht so, das interessiert die Beteiligten,
die dann wirklich an der Entscheidung mitwirken, herzlich wenig.
Deswegen bist du dann nach New York zur UN.
Genau, weil da hören die Leute einem ja bekanntlich besser zu.
Reichen mir jetzt hier mit euch Amateuren, wie bist du da hingekommen?
Tatsächlich durch eine gute Freundin, die in die Regierungsdelegation berufen
wurde, also vielleicht nochmal von vorne.
Ich war in den ersten beiden Märzwochen bei der UN in New York,
in den Headquarters sozusagen, bei der Commission of the Status of Women.
Das ist ein UN-Body, der der ECOSOC untergeordnet ist,
das ist das Gremium für Economic and Social Stuff sozusagen, und die treffen sich.
Staff, Economic and Social Council glaube ich.
Ja genau, aber ich habe ja das Body gesagt und Council, das hätte nicht mehr so gut gepasst.
Sozialgraben, sagen wir es wie es ist.
Ja genau.
Sozialgraben, Ökograben und Sozialgraben.
Naja Öko ist es ja nicht so ganz, aber egal.
Ich sage ja Eco, Economic, Ökonomie.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das war die 67. Sitzung dieser Commission,
die findet jedes Jahr statt.
Und da geht es um den Status of Women, also Gender Equality Themen.
Und dieses Mal war das über Thema Tech and Innovation and Gender Inequalities.
Und dann ist es auf Tech and Innovation and Gender Inequalities.
Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, allgemein formuliert.
Ja deswegen waren wir auch 14 Tage in New York, um rauszufinden,
was das bedeutet. Das wird Khaleesi uns ja jetzt erzählen.
Naja, also ich kann ja sagen, was wir dachten, worum es gehen wird und dann
kann ich euch sagen, worum es wirklich ging.
Was dachtest du?
Also wir dachten, ja cool, also erstmal war ja die Frage, wie ich da überhaupt
hingekommen bin. Also eine gute Freundin von mir ist in der Regierungsdelegation
gewesen und dann ist irgendwie aufgefallen, dass da nicht so sonderlich viele
Digitalos rumrennen, sondern halt mehr so Frauenrechtlerinnen.
Ist natürlich doof, wenn es um Technologie und Innovation gehen soll.
Und dann wurde ich entsprechend vorgeschlagen und der Deutsche Frauenrat hat mich dann mitgenommen.
Der Deutsche Frauenrat? Was ist denn der Deutsche Frauenrat?
Das ist auch ein...
Ja, der Deutsche Frauenrat ist der Deutsche Frauenrat. Für Frauenkram.
So wie Öko-Kram und Sozial-Kram.
Von wem ist der Deutsche Frauenrat?
Richtig gute Programmierung.
Das war ein Witz, muss man auch drüber lachen können.
Von wem ist der Deutsche Frauenrat? Ist der ein eingetragener Verein?
Oder ist das ein Teil der...
Also ich habe mich nicht mit dem Deutschen Frauenrat beschäftigt.
Ah, okay.
Also ich habe das Ticket von denen bekommen und dann habe ich gesagt, danke.
New York, New York.
Ne, bezahlt wird das ja nicht, ne? Also das muss man dazu sagen.
Das Funding muss ich mir noch selber suchen.
Der Deutsche Frauenrat, der Deutsche Frauenrat, Lobby der Frauen in der Deutschen
EV ist ein deutscher Dachverband mit Sitz in Berlin. Vereinigung von bündesweit
rund 60 Organisationen.
Genau, du weißt Bescheid.
Ich lese Wikipedia, nur dass wir das jetzt auch mal gesagt haben.
Wikipedia? Hast du nicht Chat-GPT gefragt?
Nee, soll ich Chat-GPT fragen?
Wäre wahrscheinlich nicht die richtige Antwort. Gut, jetzt bist du dahin.
Du dachtest, es geht um Innovationen?
Nein, also das Oberthema war Technologie und Innovation und Gender Inequalities.
Und das ist ja auch irgendwie ein Thema, was der EU am Herzen liegt.
und ich dachte ja cool, dann kann man mal so auf der Meta-EU-Ebene darüber sprechen,
was es denn für systematische Probleme gibt und wie die im Zusammenhang mit Technologie stehen.
Die diese Probleme benennen, dass man so ein besseres Bild davon bekommt.
Naja, also ist ja jetzt nicht, also beispielsweise, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die geringe Rate an Frauen in derartigen Berufen...
Genau, aber also ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Thema gewesen,
da vielleicht gleich nochmal zu, aber ich glaube, dass das, also das was ich
mit systematischen Problemen meine, und das ist dann das Narrativ,
auf das man da immer stößt, Die tun immer so, als wenn das Internet daran schuld
ist, dass es diese Ungleichheiten gibt.
Also es ist so, wenn wir das Internet irgendwie dicht machen oder todregulieren,
dann haben wir auch keine Genderungerechtigkeiten mehr.
Das ist ein interessanter Ansatz.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob der weit trägt.
Genau, der trägt nicht besonders weit. Möchtest du noch mehr Alkohol?
Das Wasser vom Tim.
Okay, den Rest aber bitte auf Ex, ja. Genau, der trägt nicht besonders weit,
genau, aber darum hätte es ja gehen können, dass man so sagt,
man guckt so, wie die Verbindungen sind.
Worum es tatsächlich gegangen ist, das hast du ja ganz richtig gesagt,
ist so ein bisschen der Glaube, man könnte einfach dafür sorgen,
dass es mehr, das ist ein Thema, was wir schon irgendwie seit zehn Jahren behandelt
haben. Ich glaube, seitdem ich Informatik studiere, hat sich,
Also hat sich das Narrativ nicht geändert und die Situation leider auch nicht.
Dass wenn wir nur mehr Frauen in Technikberufen haben, dann hätten wir auch
viel weniger Probleme mit Technik.
Und wir müssen einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass wir mehr Frauen haben,
die programmieren und dann wird alles gut.
Vielleicht nicht alles, aber zumindest mal ein Teil.
Genau.
Okay und jetzt kommst du da an und sagst, du dachtest über diese Themen würdest
du sprechen, aber sie haben über andere sprechen wollen.
Ja, also ich glaube mein Highlight war, der Secretary General sagte in irgendeinem
Vortrag, dass Algorithmen ja so diskriminierend seien wegen der AI.
Und das Problem ist, die meisten Personen, die da so rumlaufen,
kennen den Unterschied zwischen Internet und Plattform nicht.
Das heißt, das wird irgendwie alles zusammengeschmissen.
Algorithmen ist allgemein ein Ausdruck für jegliche Form von Software.
Von Böse, ja.
Ne, von Software. Also Algorithms hier, Algorithms da und die Algorithmen sind an allem schuld.
Und das ist auch so ein ganz, also man denkt ja, man fährt da ja hin und denkt
so, ich bin jetzt hier eingeladen, um nach New York zu fliegen,
dann werde ich ja noch irgendeinen gewissen Impact haben. Vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr als im Digitalausschuss drüber.
Weit gefehlt. Das Prinzip ist, jedes Land hat Verhandelnde da sitzen,
die hinter verschlossenen Türen ihre Willensbekundungen verhandeln für diese
Commission of Women, die da am Ende rauskommt.
Und die Zivilgesellschaft hat so nette Parallel-Events, wo sie über Themen,
die das betreffen, diskutieren können.
Ohne Einfluss zu nehmen auf das Verhandeln.
Damit sie nicht stören. Kriegen sie so ein Schnittchen irgendwie so.
Nee, Schnittchen gibt's nicht. Also es gibt ein Offizier.
Nicht mal Schnittchen.
Was für Leute, bist denn da gelandet?
Ja, New York ist teuer.
Okay, aber da kann man ja Schnittchen...
Im Bundestag.
Ja, aber das hat die Zivilgesellschaft organisiert.
Es gibt mehrere Tracks in diesem Programm, ein offizielles, wo dann auch alle
Länder ihre Statements vorlesen.
Und dann gibt es außerhalb von dem UN-Gebäude, das heißt das UN Church Center.
Wirklich kein Witz, am Anfang dachte ich, als ich mir das Programm anguckt habe,
Church Center, okay zu diesen komischen
christlichen fundamentalistischen Veranstaltungen gehe ich nicht.
Turns out, da waren alle zivilgesellschaftlichen Veranstaltungen.
Und das ist so ein Gebäude so ein bisschen außerhalb von der GA,
wo man auch ohne Badge, also man kriegt halt so ein Badge, wo man sich so einscannen
muss, das ist auch übrigens ein System, was der CCC schon gehackt hat.
Und dann kommt man halt in dieses Hauptgebäude und auch in die GA,
also in diese General Assembly, das ist so dieser große Saal mit irgendwie so
einem Marmor Ding und dann ist da so das United Nations Logo drauf,
also das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Also das ist der UN-Saal?
Der UN-Saal, genau.
Da sitzt man dann drin und hört sich was an über AI und Algorithmen.
Und das ist dann auf dem Niveau, was du gerade so angedeutet hast?
Das war tatsächlich, ich saß in diesem Saal und...
Wie viele Leute passen da rein, wäre das was für ein Kongress?
Ja, aber die Organisation war weitaus schlechter als beim Kongress.
Also ich hab drei Stunden für mein Batch angestanden.
Pff, Altenfänger.
Da können wir denen helfen.
Tim, das ist aber wirklich ein schöner Raum hier.
Kannst du das anwerfen?
Ne, das müssen die da oben machen.
Hier, das ist dieser Raum, Tim.
Ich hab das schon mal gesehen.
Da würdest du auch nochmal eine Eröffnung für den Kongress machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da könnten wir auch zu dritt gut sitzen, glaube ich, da oben.
Achso, für Podcasts, das wäre mal was.
Vielleicht so zur nächsten.
In dem Raum hast du gesessen und da hat jemand dann irgendwie mehr oder weniger
Verschwörungstheorien über AI verbreitet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Verschwörungstheorien waren. Ich glaube,
das ist einfach Unwissenheit an einigen Stellen.
Schon klar. Und wer war das?
Guterres heißt der?
Guterres, ja. Der ist der Generalsekretär.
Oder der Chief Feminist der UN, wie auch auf diesem Event gerne gesagt wurde.
Am Frauentag haben sie auch alle Männer aufstehen lassen und wir mussten klatschen
dafür, dass die uns so toll helfen mit der Gleichberechtigung.
Nein, das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Und dann müsst ihr euch vorstellen, steht da so ein Typ und das war ungefähr
so voll mit Frauen wie hier, nimmt sein Handy und filmt so alle Frauen, die klatschen.
Nein.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst?
Doch. Und wir waren alle so, okay, cool, I guess.
Das ist Fremdschämen auf internationalem Level.
Nun ja, genau.
Wo waren wir?
Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Und wer hat euch da zum Klatschen aufgefordert? Antonio Guterres.
Die Moderatorin, die den Frauentag angeleitet hat.
Aber das ist ungefähr so der Stand der Dinge bei der UN.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu noch sagen soll.
Eine Veranstaltung ohne Wirkung, ohne Ergebnis.
Genau, da muss man halt auch nochmal wieder sagen, liebe deutsche Bundesregierung,
wenn ihr doch Leute dahin schickt zum Verhandeln,
dann fragt euch eure zivilgesellschaftlichen Expertinnen vorher.
Also man kann ja vorher Feedback einholen. Das ist natürlich nicht passiert.
Es gab dann so drei Briefings, wo sie uns dann erzählt haben,
was sie gerade verhandelt haben. Und dann war es das auch wieder.
Was haben sie so verhandelt?
Das ist noch nicht zu Ende fertig. Aber in der Regel, also es gibt halt am Anfang
so ein Zero Draft, wo so ein grober Plan steht, was da drinsteht.
Sondern dann wird tatsächlich sehr viel über Wortlaute verhandelt.
Das machen wir hier eigentlich auch immer.
Vielleicht sollten wir die Bundesregierung darauf bringen, dass sie mehr über
Wortlaute verhandelt und weniger über Digitalisierung. Vielleicht würde das
weniger Schaden anrichten.
Gibt es irgendwelche neuen schädlichen Initiativen, die wir zu befürchten haben,
die sich in diesem Kontext...
Ja. Ich bin da ja auch so ein bisschen hingefahren,
weil ich gedacht habe, so perspektivisch, die Zwergkontrolle ist ja bald vorbei,
dann bin ich ja arbeitslos, dann habe ich ja wieder Freizeit und das wäre ja irgendwie ungünstig.
Weiß ich gar nicht, was ich da machen soll.
Und ein großes Thema, ich habe es gestern auch ganz kurz in meinem Talk angerissen,
war der Global Digital Compact. kompakt.
Kompakt? was ist denn kompakt? Kompakt, das Internet kompakt.
Ist das eine Abkürzung, kompakt?
Nee, das heißt wirklich so, das ist eine UN-Bezeichnung, das heißt,
bei der UN ist das immer super spannend, man denkt immer da passieren voll wichtige
Sachen und voll viele Sachen sind halt nur so Willensbekundungen,
die nicht rechtlich bindend sind.
Ja klar.
Also da haben die sich mal auf irgendwas geeinigt, das ist dann irgendwie so
eine Leitplanke, kann man sich dran halten, muss man aber nicht.
Und der liebe Guterres hat, ja ich weiß gar nicht wie das Programm heißt,
aber er hat halt gesagt, naja wir haben ja irgendwie so ein Problem mit diesem
Internet, also das ist ja alles auch echt gefährlich und explosiv und auch relevant
für Außenpolitik, wir müssen da mal was machen.
Wir müssen mal irgendwie eine globale Willensbekundung zur Digitalisierung haben.
Ein Kompakt, ein Abkommen. Ja, wie ich gerade festgestellt habe,
man lernt ja nie aus, aber das heißt tatsächlich im politischen Bereich Abkommen. Guck an, kompakt.
Okay, und jetzt, was wollen, Sie wollen ein globales, digitales Abkommen? Bauen.
Also, es gibt so zwei Richtungen, wie das gehen kann.
Und was wollen Sie da, welche Probleme meinen Sie dann zu lösen?
Alle, nein, also es gibt ja so,
es gibt ja eigentlich, also wissen wir alle, Internetregulierung hat Hochkonjunktur,
irgendwie jedes Land baut irgendwie, bau dir deine eigene Internetregulierung
und wie die Briten sagen würden, we will make Great Britain the safest country in the Internet.
Make Great Britain Great Again, ja.
Das haben die so tatsächlich bei der UN gesagt.
Das ist auch echt durch, ey, das Land.
So was von.
Auf jeden Fall wollen sie sozusagen diesem Negativ-Trend,
so Internetfragmentierung und solchen Geschichten entgegenwirken,
aber halt auch so grundlegende Probleme, wie zum Beispiel Gender-Based-Violence ansprechen.
Was da aber wirklich hinter steht und ich glaube, das ist das,
was man wissen sollte, die möchten eigentlich ganz gerne an das Multistakeholder-Modell
von Internetstandardisierung ran.
Und sie wollen dann diejenigen sein, die die Standards schreiben, oder?
Genau, die wollen das dann genauso wie bei der Konferenz, wo ich war,
so hinter verschlossenen Türen gerne selber ausdiskutieren. Tolle Idee.
Und der Prozess ist auch super interessant.
Wir versuchen uns da gerade so ein bisschen reinzuhacken. Also ohne Hacken kommt man da nicht weit.
Es gibt jetzt Konsultationen, die bis zum 30. April eingesammelt werden und
es ist wahrscheinlich so wie die Konsultation von der EU-Kommission.
Vielen Dank, schöne Konsultation haben Sie da und tschüss, haben wir euch ja
gefragt, aber jetzt machen wir trotzdem, was wir wollen.
Das heißt, das wird jetzt nochmal spannend, wie es da weitergeht und sehr viele Menschen,
die sich auch mit Internetstandardisierung beschäftigen, sind doch ein bisschen besorgt,
dass die UN irgendwie versucht, da dieses Multi-Stakeholder-Modell gegebenenfalls
kaputt zu machen, weil so Akteurinnen wie Russland und China haben natürlich
nicht so viel Interesse daran, dass die Nerds das weiter betreiben.
Um nichts zu sagen, gar keins.
Das wollte ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Naja, das kann man zwischen den Zeilen schon rauslesen.
Ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Okay, aber sonst, hast du wenigstens noch irgendwie Spaß in New York gehabt?
Ja, also...
Ich kann jetzt nicht so überzeugend ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ja, also New York ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr, sehr coole Stadt.
Ich habe tatsächlich wirklich sehr viel Zeit in der UN und in solchen Sachen
verbracht und auch versucht das so rauszufinden und hab versucht mit dem Zeitunterschied
irgendwie Europa-Stadtkontrolle-Arbeit zu machen.
Aber ja, New York ist schon nett, wohnen wollen würde ich da nicht.
Bisschen anstrengend, ja.
Es ist sehr laut, das fand ich wirklich krass. Also ich bin in Berlin angekommen
und hab gedacht krass, also so wie wenn man aus der Stadt in den Wald geht so
ungefähr war das Gefühl.
Naja, so also mit anderen Worten, die UN ist auch bewegt vom KI Thema.
Ja natürlich, weil das ist ja der Grund warum Algorithmen so diskriminierend sind.
Ja also überhaupt künstliche Intelligenz, der Begriff schon,
also das ist ja irgendwie das Thema gerade, hat man so den Eindruck?
Hat man den Eindruck.
Hat man den Eindruck, ist halt einfach mal so das Thema, außer hier vielleicht,
oder? Ja, man sieht ja schon, CCC setzt noch auf richtige Intelligenz.
Echt? Genau.
Aber es ist natürlich absehbar, spürbar schon, dass jetzt auch hier so eine
Multilevel-Debatte losgegangen ist.
Wo wird das alles hinführen? Wir werden alle sterben auf der einen Seite.
Vorher noch arbeitslos.
Das ist ja fast wie sterben.
Wir verlieren alle unsere Jobs, aber natürlich auch immer an die FDP denken,
die große Chance für die Zukunft.
Jeder kann es schaffen, auch die KI.
Ja, also mit KI wird alles toller und das Ganze ist jetzt durchweigt von den
merkwürdigsten Kommentaren,
die auch aus den merkwürdigsten Ecken kommen.
Sogar Elon Musk fängt jetzt an davor zu warnen, selbst einer der Hauptinvestoren
und Betreiber dieser Systeme.
Und ja, weiß nicht, wäre vielleicht mal ganz gut, hier mal so ein bisschen unsere
eigene Perspektive durch den Kopf rollen zu lassen.
Was ja glaube ich jetzt offensichtlich ist und klar ist, ist,
dass wir jetzt so einen Punkt erreicht haben, wo so, also jeder hat jetzt so
ein bisschen so seinen Chat-GPT-Moment gehabt, vielleicht war es auch vorher
schon das Ding mit den Bildern und so weiter.
Also man merkt so, okay, alles klar, wir durchleben jetzt in diesem Jahr und
im letzten Jahr natürlich auch schon so ein bisschen, Je nachdem,
woran man es jetzt genau festmachen möchte, so die nächste.
Revolution, eine spürbare Umwälzung, eine Veränderung der Kräfteverhältnisse,
wo bestimmte Technologien einen Einfluss haben.
wo es gefühlt auf so ziemlich alles einen Einfluss hat.
Sowohl Medien, für die Softwareentwicklung, für das Softwaredesign hat es einen
großen Einfluss und vor allem gewinnt man das Gefühl,
dass es so viel Einfluss an so vielen Stellen gerade versucht zu entwickeln,
dass das für viele jetzt auch so ein Bedrohungsszenario ist.
das nächste große Bedrohungsszenario.
Da ist vielleicht auch was dran. Kann man ja nicht komplett von der Hand weisen,
dass jetzt auf einmal so Sachen, ich meine, blättern wir mal so ein bisschen zurück.
Ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwierig in die Zukunft zu gucken.
Später kommt einem das immer alles so vollkommen selbstverständlich vor.
Aber ich war mir, sagen wir mal zum Beispiel vor zehn Jahren auch schon so sicher,
Wir werden irgendwann an diesem Punkt kommen, wo der Google selbstverständlich
auch alle Podcasts sich transkribiert bekommt.
Dass das irgendwann mal passieren wird, war mir irgendwie klar.
Ich hätte jetzt aber keine Hausnummer dran machen können und ich hätte auch
nicht genau sagen können, welche Technologie das Ganze ermöglichen wird.
Aber ich bin einfach davon ausgegangen, dass auch wenn man vor 15 Jahren so
einen Podcast gesprochen hat, dass es dann irgendwann auch in der Suchmaschine auftaucht.
Selbst wenn ich das selber nicht transkribiert habe. Also eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung,
was irgendwann mal vielleicht so passieren könnte, denke ich,
haben wir dann irgendwie alle.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, dass nicht nur das jetzt ermöglicht wird,
und auf der anderen Seite, dieses Erzeugen von Bildern hätte ich mir so nicht
vorstellen können. Ganz ehrlich.
Also deswegen finde ich eigentlich auch, zu sagen, dass es jetzt gerade eine
Revolution ist, glaube ich nicht falsch.
Ganz einfach, weil es wenige Wochen bevor man so diese ersten Mid-Journey und
Stable Diffusion und sonst was Dinge gesehen hat,
dass es im Prinzip, wenn man sich nicht vorstellen konnte, dass das in dieser
Qualität zeitnah möglich sein würde.
Und das heißt, es hat keine Evolution stattgefunden oder Disruption nennt man das dann.
Und das gleiche bei den Large Language Models, was ja eine komplett andere Technologie
ist, oder eine komplett andere Anwendung dieser Technologie ist,
die wir gerne zusammenwerfen.
Wir haben dieses Bilder generieren, das ist im Prinzip,
man kann der KI etwas sagen und sie malt was Schönes, oder dieses Large Language Models,
wo man Dinge fragen kann, mit ihr interagieren kann, schon etwas andere Dinge,
die diese KIs gelernt haben, sind unterschiedliche neuronale Modelle für unterschiedliche
Arten von Input, Output.
Aber beides war in dem Ausmaß, denke ich, bevor es veröffentlicht wurde und
noch nicht so vorstellbar, dass das jetzt schon jemand so hätte.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, ist auf jeden Fall revolutionär oder disruptiv.
Hat glaube ich zur Folge, dass wir, also selbst wenn wir evolutionär dahin gekommen
wären, hätten wir ja nicht die gesellschaftliche Hoheit darüber gewinnen können,
weil wir viel zu langsam sind.
Und jetzt stehen wir quasi vor so einem Moment, dass es diese Technologie gibt,
die wir als Gesellschaft in keiner Form darauf vorbereitet sind.
Wir wissen, dass sie wahrscheinlich sehr große Chancen hat, diese Technologie.
Wir erkennen aber natürlich auch ein paar Risiken. Man muss jetzt irgendwie
überlegen, wie gehen wir jetzt mit diesen gesellschaftlichen Veränderungen Untertitel
im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017.
Letzte Woche war ich bei Markus Lanz zu dem Thema, wo es im Prinzip um Fake News ging.
Also man kann jetzt diese wunderschönen Bilder, Donald Trump wehrt sich gegen
die Verhaftung on 5th Avenue oder sowas, wunderschöne Bilder.
Der Papst mit diesem traumhaften Mantel, da sind spitzen Ideen entstanden.
Und wir werden jetzt relativ bald in einer Welt sein, in der sowas nicht mehr
einfach zu erkennen ist und in der gleichzeitig auch echte Bilder diskreditiert
werden können, als ist von einer KI gefälscht worden.
Das heißt wir werden Probleme bekommen mit dem was wir belegen können noch.
Was wir belegen können oder was vielleicht unglaubhaft gemacht wird.
Ja und wir haben ja auch noch dieses ganze Thema Instagram Filter,
die dann natürlich auch noch da mit rein spielen.
Dann gibt's ja die Instagram Filter, wo man sich dann auch, wo Menschen sich
selber irgendwie in die Echtstörungen fotografieren.
Dann gibt es den zweiten Teil Computerentscheidungen, die jetzt irgendwie gesellschaftliche
Ungleichheiten weiter verstärken.
Da wissen wir jetzt schon mal zumindest von Khaleesi, dass Antonio Guterres
das nicht verstanden hat, wie da die Zusammenhänge sind, dass die Ungleichheiten
zuerst da waren und jetzt verstärkt werden.
Und dann haben wir noch diesen ganzen Bereich Large Language Models,
wo wir irgendwie mit den Computern sprechen können und die im Brustton der Überzeugung
entweder echt kluge Dinge sagen oder ziemlich beknackte Dinge und wir aber auch
den Unterschied noch nicht feststellen können.
Und ich glaube, da werden schon ein paar gesellschaftliche Grundwerte oder Grundannahmen
sehr auf die Probe gestellt.
Die Frage ist, wie gehen wir jetzt damit um?
Und das, was ich voraussagen würde für die nächsten Jahre, ist,
natürlich gehen wir damit auf die dümmstmögliche und destruktivste Weise um.
So dass wir jetzt entweder das Kind mit dem Bart ausgießen oder irgendwie sehenden
Auges in irgendwelche echt unschönen Phänomene uns begeben.
Ich glaube auch, dass wir es am Ende, also es wird noch nicht so bald dazu kommen,
dass die KI den Planeten übernimmt und die Menschheit zerstört,
obwohl es das Richtige wäre.
Aber das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Also auf dem Weg wird's jetzt echt mal ein bisschen unangenehm,
würde ich sagen. Für eine Zeit.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall jetzt auch erstmal noch sehr unterhaltsam.
Also ich meine jetzt haben wir ja noch die Phase wo alles irgendwie auch noch super neu ist.
Ich meine machen wir uns mal klar was auf einmal so geht. Also nochmal so ein
Beispiel, wo ich auch wirklich beeindruckt war. Also Chatty Pitty so,
okay, so man sitzt da so das erste Mal davor, okay, oh okay,
ist ja interessant und so was.
Liest man schon so, andere Leute haben so total komplexe Sachen eingegeben.
Okay, wie weit geht denn jetzt hier irgendwie das Rabbit Hole?
Erzählt dann irgendwie so eine komplette Geschichte und merkt so,
okay, wow, Chief Summarizer in Chief, der so das ganze Internet gelesen hat
und der jetzt irgendwie alles zusammenfassen kann.
Und da war ich dann schon so beeindruckt. Und dann hab ich irgendwann gemerkt
so, oh fuck, ich kann jetzt irgendwie mitten in dem Dialog die Sprache wechseln
Und es ist immer noch dasselbe Gespräch.
Oder ich frag auf Deutsch und er notiert mir oben schon die Zusammenfassung
so als Kurztitel dann einfach auf Englisch.
Weil es irgendwie völlig egal ist, in welcher Sprache du mit diesem System redest.
Und das ist ja der Urtraum eigentlich der künstlichen Intelligenz,
wo der Begriff ja herkommt, ist ja von Linguisten, die irgendwie der Meinung
waren, Intelligenz kannst du daran festmachen, dass menschliche Sprache verstanden wird.
Mit dem Verstehen ist das natürlich jetzt so ein Ding.
Weil man wird ja nicht wirklich verstanden.
Ich denke das haben es viele wahrscheinlich auch schon gemerkt.
Also ich hab so in meinen Experimenten, klar man ist immer so beeindruckt und
denkt sich so, ah ok super.
Und wo es halt wirklich rockt ist halt so auf Ideen kommen, schlag mir mal was
vor, was gibt's denn so und so.
Also wenn man da so einfach mal breit ausfächern möchte, verschiedene Ideen
bekommen möchte, wo man so selber drüber nachdenken kann, dafür ist es einfach perfekt.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du anfängst wirklich dran zu glauben und denkst,
du kriegst jetzt irgendwie Fakten geliefert, da wird's dann halt schwierig.
Und was ich ganz interessant fand ist, wir alle wissen ja, was so das Problem
mit Google ist und all diesen ganzen werbefinanzierten Dingen.
Am Ende wollen sie dir irgendwie immer die Werbung reinschieben,
weil das ist ja das, was das Geld bringt.
Der eigentliche Incentive ist in irgendeiner Form was zu generieren,
was dich dazu bringt etwas zu klicken, was denen dann Geld bringt,
die dir diese Informationen bereitstellen.
Jetzt hast du auf einmal so eine Suchmaschine, die eigentlich überhaupt gar
keine Werbung einblendet, also zumindest noch nicht oder wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was weiß ich, was in diesen Entscheidungsprozess alles mit reingeht,
aber ich hab dann so das Gefühl, dass es so ein bisschen so...
Wie sag ich das jetzt richtig? Also ihr habt ja sicherlich schon mal so Leute
getroffen, die sehr von sich überzeugt sind.
Ja, dich zum Beispiel.
Also mich zum Beispiel. Einen kenn ich.
Also ich glaub sogar zwei, wenn ich so mich umgucke.
Was? Als wir jung waren.
Als wir jung waren. Und da ist man ja so ein Heißsporn und dann steckt man so
voll in seinem Thema drin und dann kommt irgendjemand und fragt einen auch noch
dazu aus, dann kann man so voll Auskunft geben.
Total im Thema und so und dann drifte so die ganze Thematik in so Bereiche rein,
wo man eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel geplant hat.
Aber man ist immer noch total überzeugend und dann fängt man auch irgendwann
an, einfach Quatsch zu erzählen.
Mit derselben Werbe, einfach weil man es nicht ertragen kann,
dann nicht mehr auf dieselbe Art und Weise angenommen zu werden.
Und ich glaube, so ist es dann auch so ein bisschen mit diesem KI-System.
Weil deren einziger Auftrag ist, dir in irgendeiner Form eine Antwort liefern
zu können. Und sie tun das sogar, wenn sie es eigentlich nicht mehr können.
Das heißt dann fangen sie ja irgendwann an zu lügen, weil es einfach nicht mehr anders geht.
Und sie behaupten ja dann auch, dass sie nicht gelogen haben,
das ist ja auch immer noch sehr interessant.
Ja, oder man erzählt einem irgendwas richtiges und dann sagt man so,
ja aber du weißt aber auch, dass das nicht so ist. Ja das tut mir jetzt wirklich furchtbar leid.
Das ist natürlich ganz anders, ne. Kommt dann total durcheinander und dann ist
es einfach nur noch wirklich Unsinn.
Also da ist dann wirklich mal wieder so Medienkompetenz gefragt,
nur mal ehrlich, was habt ihr da für Hoffnung? Mann, schau dir mal an,
was die Leute in den letzten 2-3 Jahren für eine Scheiße geglaubt haben.
Ich glaube, also...
Ganz ohne Kaiki.
Und dann sollen die irgendwie in so einem Ding irgendwie noch klarkommen.
Also ich glaube, es gibt da so zwei Probleme. Weil du hast ja jetzt,
also auch wenn ich immer finde, dass du so ein kleiner Chat-GPT-Evangelist bist. Ähm...
Die Leute glauben immer, ich bin immer von allem Evangelist, worüber ich rede.
Ja, stimmt nur bei mir. Nein,
aber ich glaube da sind so zwei Probleme, weil jetzt auf einmal ist was,
was sehr lange sehr weit weg war sehr nah dran und jetzt glauben die Leute nicht
nur, dass es total cool ist, sondern dass sie auch verstanden haben, was es tut.
Und ich finde die Chat-Kontrolle ist eigentlich das beste Beispiel dafür,
dass Leute denken, weil Chat-GPT jetzt die jetzt weise Antworten geben kann,
können wir auch Grooming erkennen.
Und das dann den Leuten zu verklickern, dass wir da noch nicht so ganz angekommen
sind und dass das auch wahrscheinlich nicht passieren wird, ist sehr schwierig,
aber alle sind auf einmal irgendwie Chief Technical KI Experts,
weil sie fünf Tage mit Chachipiti gestellt haben.
Also ich zum Beispiel.
Also jetzt waren sie die ganze Zeit...
Ich kann nicht beruhigen, ich hab da schon ein gewisses Maß an Skepsis aufgebaut.
Das wollte ich gerade gar nicht sagen, aber wir sind jetzt von den Viren-Experten
zu den KI-Experten gewandert. Das ist so der Trend.
Also was ich denke,
ist dieser technologische Wandel,
mit dem ein gesellschaftlicher Wandel einhergehen wird jetzt,
das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht, wenn wir in irgendeiner Weise in der
Lage wären, den als Gesellschaft informiert zu gestalten, statt davon überrannt
und überrollt zu werden.
Und leider scheint mir das so zu sein, dass wir die letzten Jahrzehnte von Technologien
immer überrannt wurden.
völlig absurde, also die Mitte der Gesellschaft immer noch relativ absurde Vorstellungen
davon hatte, wie eine bestimmte Technologie funktioniert oder warum und was
die Problemlösung wäre.
Deswegen bin ich wirklich alarmiert von dem, was du da von der UN erzählst,
dass sie halt wirklich offenbar es schaffen, auf einer dermaßen Flughöhe zu
sein, dass sie ja fundamentale Zusammenhänge nicht verstanden haben.
Und das macht natürlich Sorgen im Hinblick darauf, wie diese Leute die Gesellschaften
lenken und vielleicht führen oder auch begrenzen im Umgang damit.
Ein Beispiel, Italien hat jetzt Chat-GPT verboten.
Wegen Verstoßes gegen Datenschutz- und Jugendschutzregeln. Ich glaube sogar,
dass das wahrscheinlich stimmt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich lange brauche, bis ChatGPT irgendetwas macht,
was mindestens ab 16 ist, ohne vorher vernünftig verifiziert zu haben,
dass ich 16 bin und damit hat es irgendeine Jugendschutzregel sicherlich verletzt.
Im Datenschutz wurde halt argumentiert, dass es diese ganzen Informationen,
die es ja da aus dem Internet gesammelt hat, für deren Verarbeitung quasi nicht
das Recht hat und deswegen quasi das Ergebnis dieses Language Model
quasi gegen Datenschutzrecht verstößt und teilweise Information preisgibt und
so weiter, die es nicht haben dürfte.
Und dann haben die gesagt, innerhalb von 20 Tagen, also haben sie OpenAI geschrieben hier,
ihr dürft das jetzt mit sofortiger Wirkung nur noch eingeschränkt machen,
müsst uns in 20 Tagen sagen, wie ihr euch an unsere Gesetze haltet,
andernfalls 20 Millionen Euro oder bis zu 4% des Jahresumsatzes.
Und dann hat OpenAI gesagt, okay, wir stellen den unseren Dienst in Italien
ein, geben den Leuten, die bisher bezahlt haben, Geld zurück und fertig.
Würde aber, wären wir jetzt in der Situation, dass die Italiener sagen,
das ist ein Verstoß gegen das Datenschutzrecht, dann wäre es eben auch ein Verstoß
gegen die EU-Datenschutzgrundverordnung und damit auch in ganz Europa so nicht nutzbar.
Das kann jetzt positiv oder negativ, also es kann richtig oder falsch sein,
Aber ich denke, das Ergebnis, diese Technologie jetzt erstmal zu verbieten,
ist vermutlich nicht der richtige Schritt.
Also wenn meine Hypothese hält,
dass es eigentlich die Gesellschaft ist, die für diese Technologie nicht bereit
ist, dann glaube ich nicht, dass man durch das Verbot des Zuganges das Problem löst.
Ja und ich glaube da ist halt auch das Thema, dass wir uns sehr viel mehr mit
KI-Regulierung beschäftigen, als mit Ansätzen, was du jetzt auch meintest,
um die Gesellschaft auf den Umgang damit vorzubereiten.
Beispiel Echtheit von Bildern und Videos.
Dann kommen die Technokraten und sagen, ja pass auf, wir machen einfach in jede Kamera,
die kriegt ihr eigenes Zert und die signiert quasi ihre Ausgabedaten Und dann
kann man quasi beweisen, dass dieses Bild mit einer Nikon-Kamera zum Beispiel
gemacht wurde und seitdem nicht verändert wurde.
Und das funktioniert natürlich. Hat auch Nikon glaube ich 2011 oder so schon gebaut.
Hat natürlich auch sofort jemand das Zert aus dieser Nikon-Kamera rausgeholt
und kann jetzt damit jedes Bild von Mid-Journey oder sonst was natürlich signieren.
Also die Idee das technisch zu lösen, glaube ich nicht, dass sie weit trägt.
Aber das ist tatsächlich auch die Idee, die die UN zu vielen Themen hat.
Also das ist so diese High-Level-Annahme, dass wir uns das Problem mit Technik
geschaffen haben und dass wir es deswegen auch mit Technik lösen können.
Das ist der andere Rat, die andere Empfehlung, die ich jetzt oft gehört habe auf Twitter.
Wenn AI Fälschungen macht, dann müssen wir jetzt halt eine AI machen,
die Fälschungen erkennt.
Und das Schöne ist, wenn du dir jetzt so eine AI anguckst, wie viele Fehler
die macht und wie viel Quatsch die auch mitunter redet, wäre es natürlich echt
spitze, wenn die sich auch nur einmal täuscht bei einem wichtigen Video.
Das heißt, wir werden irgendwie für die Menschen etwas finden müssen.
Jetzt kommen diese Leute, ich hab das überhaupt nicht für ernst genommen,
ich dachte das wäre ein Scherz,
dass Elon Musk wieder irgendwas getwittert hat, Und schreiben einen offenen
Brief, AI Labs soll jetzt sechs Monate, mindestens sechs Monate,
nicht mehr weiter seine Systeme trainieren.
Open AI meinst du?
Open AI, ja. Die sollen also keine Systeme bauen, die sollen nichts besseres als GPT4 bauen.
Für sechs Monate. Und dann?
Das ist halt auch, also ich hab dazu ein Interview mit dem CEO von Google gehört,
der halt auch gesagt hat, naja, da wird sich halt eh keiner dran halten.
Natürlich nicht. Und vor allen Dingen wird dann, also die einreiben sich dann die Hände und sagen,
ja geil, jetzt bauen die nicht weiter, jetzt können wir nochmal,
jetzt können wir nochmal unseren Approach zu diesem Mist wahr machen und das
wird nichts bringen, weil das ja nicht zu reflektierten Überlegungen führen wird.
Und ich finde auch die Mischung an Menschen, die diesen Brief unterschrieben
haben, sehr interessant.
Elon Musk, Steve Wozniak, Yuval Noah Harari, also zwei davon schätze ich durchaus,
aber dass sie irgendwie so weit nicht denken können.
Wer ist nochmal der Dritte?
Ein israelischer Philosoph, Autor von Homo Deus und Sapiens und 21 Lessons for the 21st Century.
Ja das ist ein merkwürdiges...
Gar nicht Tel Aviv, Jerusalem.
Okay, ist ja nicht so weit weg.
Ja, Wozniak, okay gut.
Ich frage mich ernsthaft, wie die zusammengekommen sind. Und was das auch... Ich meine inwiefern...
Wenn sie jetzt sozusagen wirklich darin den Untergang sehen,
dann wird sich da mit einer sechsmonatigen Pause auch nicht viel dran ändern.
Lass uns den Untergang um sechs Monate verschieben.
Ja genau, der Komet zieht nochmal einen Kreis um die Sonne bevor er dann einschlägt.
Ich glaub nicht, dass da noch viel zu retten ist.
Und das finde ich daran auch so faszinierend, weil das die Hilflosigkeit wirklich zeigt.
Also alle sind ratlos, sehen, okay Mist, das wird hier zu Problemen führen,
ja wird's auch. Und das beste was denen einfällt ist, lass uns das vielleicht
prokrastinieren um sechs Monate.
Prokrastinators unite. Tomorrow.
Also das ist, ich meine stehen wir denn jetzt vor dem Weltuntergang?
Also ich meine vielleicht ist das ja auch schon die letzte Sendung und morgen
ist alles vorbei. Können wir vielleicht mal so ein dystopisches Szenario...
Also du meinst das nächste Mal sitze ich mit zwei von sich selbst überzeugenden
Computern auf der Bühne?
Wer sagt denn, dass du da nicht noch sitzt?
Ich ähm...
Ja, aber ich meine, malen wir doch jetzt mal auf, was ist jetzt sozusagen das
totale maximale Horrorszenario, was sich jetzt sozusagen durch die AI entfachen
kann. Wie lange dauert's, wie viel Zeit haben wir noch, bevor irgendwie alles losgeht?
Wenn man jetzt mal sagt, es läuft alles richtig scheiße. Wir haben also diesen
Fake-News-Aspekt, der ist sicherlich für die allgemeine Destabilisierung und...
Als erstes wird die AI uns ausreden, dass es sie überhaupt gibt.
Ja, aber wie denn?
Ist alles Fake News.
Also wir kriegen ja wahrscheinlich erstmal, wir müssen ja erstmal unsere Kopfhörer
die ganze Zeit tragen, damit die das auch immer wiederholen kann.
Jetzt frag konkret mal ehrlich, ich meine mal so ehrlich jetzt so richtig.
Was passiert? Es gibt keine demokratische Steuerungsmöglichkeit mehr,
weil die Menschen von unterschiedlichen Realitäten überzeugt sind,
die nicht miteinander vereinbar sind.
So was wir jetzt eh schon haben, aber noch schlimmer.
Ja genau.
Und dann sind alle arbeitslos und haben schlechte Laune deshalb.
Und wenden sich in ihrem Hass gegen im Zweifelsfall irgendwelche anderen Bevölkerungsgruppen.
Schafft aber auch wieder neue Arbeitsplätze. Also guck mal die ganzen Leute,
die zuletzt alle nur davon leben mussten, LFTs zu verkaufen,
sind jetzt auf Chat-GPT-Beratung umgestiegen.
Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Das Grillenzirpen im Bitcoin-Bereich ist wirklich sehr laut zu vernehmen.
Und jetzt machen alle so OpenAI, zehn Tipps, wie du mit ChatGPT reich werden kannst und so.
Wie du den perfekten LinkedIn-Post mit ChatGPT schreiben kannst.
Mach alles noch besser mit ChatGPT. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Aber vielleicht wird die FDP dann bald durch ChattyPetey ersetzt.
Also wir waren aber bei konkreten Beispielen.
Aber Tim, das ist doch genau das beste Beispiel dafür, dass diese Technologie
uns jetzt nicht glücklich machen wird,
wenn sie von den wirklich von den, sagen wir mal, von den am wenigsten für sagen
wir mal Nachhaltigkeit und gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt stehenden Leuten als
allererstes vermarktet wird.
Ich stelle jetzt einfach mal
kurz fest, dass wir keine klare Linie sehen direkt bis zum Weltuntergang.
Also es ist sozusagen noch eine Menge weiche Masse dazwischen,
die noch formbar ist. Also ich hab selber noch persönlich ein bisschen mit dem
Weltuntergangsszenario meine Probleme. Ich sehe das natürlich alles,
aber ich sehe ja auch Gegenbewegungen.
Es ist nur Untergang des Status Quo.
Also es wird...
Wessen?
Also ganz generell, ich glaube Linus hat das bei Markus Lanz ganz schön gesagt,
dass wir damit klarkommen müssen, dass es keine feststehenden Wahrheiten mehr gibt.
Vielleicht könnt ihr das auch einfach selber weiter ausführen.
Soll ich es nochmal sagen? Ja, sag es doch nochmal bitte. Weil ich möchte gerne
noch eine feststehende Wahrheit bevor...
Wir würden ja jetzt, wir würden doch, also in einer Welt, also es ist ja relativ
einfach denkbar eine Gesellschaft zu haben, die in der Lage wäre mit dieser
Technologie vernünftig umzugehen.
bräuchte dafür ein bisschen Kompetenz, ein bisschen positiven Blick nach vorne
und dann wäre es denkbar, dass eine solche Technologie über die Menschheit kommt
und die Welt nicht untergeht.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Welt untergehen wird. Ich denke nur,
dass wir jetzt allerhand unschöne Phänomene haben werden, weil wir nur durch
diese allerhand unschönen Phänomene hoffentlich langfristig lernen werden.
Wir haben aber hier eine Technologie, die über uns kommt, mit der wir überhaupt
nicht umzugehen wissen. Wir sagen, lass uns das sechs Monate Pause machen, lass uns das verbieten.
Also absolute Planlosigkeit im Umgang mit dieser Technologie.
Gleichzeitig glaube ich, ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir eine gesellschaftliche
Hoheit darüber kriegen.
Und wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen, diese AI ist jetzt nichts,
was irgendwie in die Hände aller kommt. Diese Modelle zu trainieren hat sicherlich
sehr sehr sehr viel Geld gekostet.
Und viele Daten.
Und sehr sehr viele Daten, die wir alle nicht haben. Und da denke ich tatsächlich,
dass hier eben potenziell eher gerade eine Technologie entsteht,
die noch mehr Machtzentralisierung hat, als was wir in diesem schönen dezentralen
Web, von dem wir alle immer geträumt haben,
haben entstehen lassen mit irgendwelchen Google, Apple, Facebook, Amazon, Microsofts.
Und jetzt kommen die, und das sind ja die einzigen, die so eine AI bauen können.
Also du brauchst ja Milliarden, um so ein GPT zu bauen. Nicht unbedingt an Menschen,
sondern an Rechenstunden, um dieses Modell zu trainieren.
Und jetzt kommt quasi diese zentralisierte neue Megatechnologie und stellt viele
gesellschaftliche Bereiche infrage und wir haben eigentlich keine Art damit umzugehen.
Also wir haben keinen, wir werden das nicht, ich sehe auch nicht,
dass wir das irgendwie demokratisch irgendwie eingehegt bekommen oder so.
außer mit irgendwelchen hilflosen, blöden Ideen.
Und das wird, klar wird das spannend, aber es wäre schöner gewesen,
wenn wir auf eine aufgeklärte, medienkompetente Gesellschaft setzen könnten,
wo wir uns jetzt keine Sorgen machen müssten, dass die sich so dumm im Umgang damit anstellen wird.
Wie hieß nochmal diese Suche nach extraterrestriellem Leben?
SETI at home.
SETI at home, genau. Das könnte ich ja auch noch kommen sehen.
Das ist sozusagen als Gegenbewegung.
SETI at home.
Ja, dass sozusagen jetzt alle Rechner auch noch den Rest ihrer verfügbaren CPU-Zyklen
irgendwie jetzt in so ein Welt-Large-Language-Model reinschmeißen,
was dann irgendwie allen gehört.
quasi so eine Wikipedia-AI, die quasi versucht, den kommerziellen Language Models
in irgendeiner Form Parodie zu bieten.
Durchaus eine Gegenbewegung, die ich sehen kann. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das so realistisch ist, aber das ist definitiv etwas, was ich mir ganz gut vorstellen kann.
Weil Wikipedia-Editoren auch so divers sind, ne?
Ja, ich meine, dieses humane Element entfällt ja und das ist ja auch Teil des Problems.
Dadurch, dass du jetzt sozusagen ausschließlich, also stimmt auch nicht ganz,
weil ich meine das was GPT uns ja dann,
und GPT generell gilt jetzt für all diese ganzen AIs, die jetzt die nächsten
Tage und Wochen noch auf uns einschlagen werden,
wie sie alle heißen von Google und so weiter, aber ihr wisst schon was ich meine,
die fassen uns ja sozusagen das Internet as it is today zusammen.
Das heißt mit all seinen ganzen Vorurteilen, mit all seinen ganzen Fehlannahmen,
mit all seinen ganzen Ungenauigkeiten versucht es da zwar in irgendeiner Form
ein Reasoning rauszuziehen, aber es ist halt letzten Endes nicht intelligenter
als sozusagen die Gesamtintelligenz dieses Planeten. Also der Mensch steckt
da auch nach wie vor drin.
Also ab und an ja.
Ab und an was?
Nee, alles gut.
Sprich dich aus, ich weiß nicht was du meinst.
Naja ab und an spuckt es auch Dinge aus, die jetzt nicht unbedingt aus dem Internet
kommen, die sich selber, also es erfindet ja auch Buchtitel zum Beispiel.
Ja aber es erfindet all das ja aus, ja aber aus dem Internet heraus,
also es ist ja sozusagen eine Schlussfolgerung dessen, was da sowieso schon
steht. Es ist ja sozusagen nur ein Versuch in irgendeiner Form aus dem ganzen
Unsinn einen Sinn zu bilden.
Was wir ja eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit probieren, das funktioniert ja manchmal
ganz gut, manchmal nicht so gut.
Worauf ich hinleiten möchte ist, mein Lieblingsthema Chancen und Risiken,
also Risiken klar sind jetzt irgendwie definitiv da, aber es ist halt auch wirklich
ein Füllhorn an Chancen, was jetzt hier sich durch diese Technologie aufmacht.
Also allein dieses gelöste Übersetzungsproblem, sage ich jetzt mal so,
das ist absehbar, der Babelfisch ist real.
Das war lange Zeit schwer vorstellbar, aber wir haben ihn vielleicht noch nicht
im Airport mit drin, aber im Prinzip läuft es ja darauf hinaus.
Du wirst in absehbarer Zeit mit einem überschaubaren Aufwand in Echtzeit alle
Sprachen verstehen und im Prinzip auch sprechen können.
Also doch Star Trek.
Anhalter erstmal, würde ich sagen. Erstmal kommt Douglas Adams.
Ich finde das toll, mal ganz ehrlich.
Das stellt ja auch keiner in Frage, dass es da positive Aspekte geben wird,
aber es wäre doch eigentlich ganz nett, die Negativen dann gleichzeitig noch
ein bisschen zu reduzieren.
Ja und vor allen Dingen dafür zu sorgen, dass die Negativen nicht überwiegen
am Ende. Ich glaube, das ist das, was wir auch gegebenenfalls auf uns zukommen sehen.
Ja okay, also ist das Glas jetzt halb voll oder halb leer?
Das würde ich Cecil B. Tief fragen.
Also was machen wir? Also nur um das Niveau der Debatte in Deutschland nochmal zu zeigen.
Wir werden jetzt nach einem Konzeptpapier von Algorithmwatch...
werden wir ein Transparenzregister haben für Teile der öffentlichen Verwaltung gewissermaßen,
bei denen automatisierte Entscheidungssysteme zum Einsatz kommen.
Also wenn du in der Verwaltung, in der öffentlichen Verwaltung,
deine Anträge oder so von einem automatisierten Entscheidungssystem behandelt
werden, Dann werden dabei auch die verwendeten Methoden öffentlich aufrufbar sein.
Das ist jetzt so das Niveau auf dem wir arbeiten. Ich finde das noch nicht mal schlecht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also das ist...
Aber es ist halt, ich meine, wir müssen hier sagen, Algorithm ist hier glaube
ich schon das richtige Wort. Das ist jetzt nicht KI, ne? Also das ist irgendwie
Computer nimmt dann nicht.
Hat dann nein gesagt, muss man noch was anderes machen. Du musst noch fünf weitere
Formulare ausfüllen, dann können wir dich behandeln oder so.
Da werden wir dann ein Transparenzregister haben. Aber mir scheinen diese Methoden
relativ starke Hilflosigkeit zu zeigen.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das sind so zwei unterschiedliche Fronten,
an denen man auch kämpft.
Also das eine ist jetzt irgendwie solche Sachen, auch gerade im öffentlichen Bereich,
wo man vielleicht auch sagt, man möchte da frühzeitig dagegen steuern,
dass die nicht so KI goes rogue in der Verwaltungsdigitalisierung machen.
Und ich glaube, das ist eigentlich eine gute Maßnahme, dem gegenzusteuern.
Aber da sind wir noch ganz weit weg von diesem ganzen Hardcore-KI-Stuff.
Da ist man vielleicht nochmal nachhaltig an der richtigen Stelle.
Aber die Frage bleibt ja offen, was machen wir mit dem Rest,
der irgendwie schon da ist und auch sich immer schneller weiterentwickelt.
Das ist dann die andere Front, die wir irgendwie abdecken müssen.
Früher haben sich immer alle über die Bombenbauanleitungen im Internet aufgeregt.
Hast du das schon ausprobiert in deiner CGPT-Studie?
Ne, aber ich denke mir so, man könnte halt jetzt, wenn es lustig ist,
ich könnte ja jetzt mir im Prinzip einen kompletten Banküberfall skripten lassen.
Da ist ja Bombenbauanleitung irgendwie ein Witz dagegen.
Andererseits sind natürlich jetzt so die Kriminellen, die das für eine tolle
Idee halten, auch wirklich gut bedient, einfach so ihre Pläne dann einfach auf
so einen amerikanischen Server eintippen.
Das könnte alles noch sehr lustig werden. Aber so ganz ehrlich,
wir schwimmen auch noch so ein bisschen in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Das muss sich alles echt noch so ein bisschen festigen.
Ja, also ich glaube aber es gibt so ein paar Personen, die da auch schon ein
bisschen länger dran arbeiten.
Also die OSZE hat zum Beispiel bei der Representative for Freedom of the Media
auch ein Projekt angehängt,
sich damit beschäftigen, was eigentlich Artificial Intelligence for Freedom
of the Media und Freedom of Expression bedeutet und wo sie auch konträr gegeneinander laufen.
Also zum einen kannst du es natürlich benutzen, um Sachen zu automatisieren,
auf der anderen Seite kannst du es für Hate Speech benutzen und wie steuerst du dann dagegen.
Das machen die auch schon seit 2020 und auch relativ detailliert,
aber das ist dann halt auch wieder so dieser Regulierungshebel,
den sie da ansetzen und nicht der Hebel von...
nachhaltigen gesellschaftlichen Aktionen.
Was hältst du denn von diesen Ideen, also bei Chat-GPT gibt es ja sehr viele
Versuche, das Ding einzuhegen, dass es nicht gewünschtes Verhalten nicht zeigt.
Also zum Beispiel Anleitungen zu selbstverletzendem Verhalten oder derartiges.
Und dann gibt es aber auch eine ganze Reihe, gibt es einen Volkssport,
die wiederum zu umgehen.
Und dann gibt es aber diese, weiß ich nicht, Freedom AI Leute,
die dann sagen, nein, hier unsere AI, die erklärt dir, wie man die Bombe baut
und die sagt dir, wie du dich umbringen kannst und sind dann da irgendwie so
Free Speech for AI Absolutionists.
Auch sehr interessantes Volk.
Glaubst du, siehst du da einen, wie würdest du da denken, was der sinnvolle Weg ist?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich glaube, dass wir im Moment so ein Problem haben und ich meine so Self-Harm
und Bomben bauen ist ja noch eine Sache, wo wir uns vielleicht relativ einig
sind, dass das problematische Dinge sind.
Aber wie bei allem sind wir auf so einer slippery slope unterwegs und was wir
ja gerade sehen ist irgendwie so ein sehr, ich sag mal, prüden und konservativen
Rückschritt in unserer Gesellschaft.
Also wir zensieren jetzt eigentlich am liebsten alles, was irgendwie sexuell sein könnte.
Irgendwie LGBTQA plus Community sind irgendwie als erstes davon betroffen und
dann meistens irgendwie weibliche Nippel.
Und die Frage ist, wohin geht die Reise dann?
Und dann haben wir natürlich dieses Problem, wir haben jetzt so eine mächtige
AI, die alle Leute benutzen. Und wenn wir darüber entscheiden,
was die Informationen sind, die Leute erhalten und was gefiltert wird.
Und die glauben dem Ganzen noch, dann haben wir auch irgendwie wieder ein Problem.
Also da beißt sich die Katze jedes Mal wieder in den Schwanz.
Also hilft es am Ende nur, wenn die Leute endlich mal klarkommen.
Genau.
Okay, ja super.
Also wir brauchen mehr Training für Menschen sozusagen.
Ja, die Menschen müssen auch mal so lange trainiert werden.
So, genug in der Zukunft gestochert. Jetzt kümmern wir uns wieder um die Veranstaltung hier.
Vielen Dank für's Dabeisein.
Gerne.
Vielen Dank für's Kommen hier zu unserer, wie nennt man das,
Sendung? Podcast? Training.
Zu diesem Training.
Zu dieser AI Training Session.
Ihr wisst ja jetzt alle Bescheid. Ansonsten freuen wir uns wie immer über euer
Feedback und all das und machen's kurz. Und tschüss, bis bald, vielen Dank.